Lo que voy a mostrarles primero, tan brevemente como pueda,
es algo de trabajo de base, una tecnología nueva
que hemos traído a Microsoft como parte de una adquisición
realizada hace casi un año exacto. Se trata de Seadragon.
Es un entorno en el que se puede interactuar en forma local o remota
con grandes cantidades de datos visuales.
Aquí estamos viendo muchos, muchos gigabytes de fotos digitales,
haciendo zoom en forma continua y sin dificultades,
haciendo panorámicas y modificaciones de cualquier tipo.
La cantidad de información que veamos,
el tamaño de las colecciones y el de las imágenes ya no son un problema.
En su mayoría son fotos de cámaras digitales comunes,
pero esta, por ejemplo, es una escaneada de la Biblioteca del Congreso,
con cerca de 300 megapíxeles.
Es lo mismo,
porque lo único que puede limitar el rendimiento
de un sistema como este es el número de píxeles de su pantalla
en un momento dado. También tiene una arquitectura muy flexible.
Este es un libro completo, un ejemplo de datos sin imágenes.
Se trata de "Casa desolada", de Dickens. Cada columna es un capítulo.
Para probarles que se trata realmente de texto, y no de una imagen,
podemos hacer algo para mostrar
que se trata de una representación real del texto; no es una imagen.
Quizá sea una forma algo artificial de leer un libro electrónico.
No la recomendaría.
Este es un caso más realista. Un ejemplar de The Guardian.
Cada imagen grande es el comienzo de una sección.
Y realmente proporciona el placer y la experiencia agradable
de leer la versión real en papel de una revista o un diario,
un tipo de medio propiamente de escalas múltiples.
También hemos hecho algo
en una esquina de este ejemplar de The Guardian.
Hemos hecho un anuncio publicitario falso con alta resolución,
mucho más de la que puede obtenerse en un anuncio común,
y le hemos incorporado otros contenidos.
Si desean ver las características de este coche, pueden hacerlo aquí.
O ver otros modelos, e incluso especificaciones técnicas.
Esto comprende algunas de las ideas
sobre anular los límites en torno a los inmuebles en pantalla.
Esperamos que esto implique el fin de las pantallas emergentes
y otros estorbos de ese tipo: ya no serían necesarios.
Por cierto, el mapeo es una de las aplicaciones realmente obvias
en una tecnología como esta.
No voy a demorarme en esto,
salvo decir que también tenemos cómo contribuir en este campo.
Estas son todas las carreteras de los EE.UU.
sobreimpresas en la parte superior de una imagen geoespacial de la NASA.
Ahora veamos algo más.
Esto está en directo en la red en este momento, pueden verlo.
Es un proyecto llamado Photosynth,
que combina dos tecnologías diferentes.
Una es Seadragon,
y la otra una investigación visual computarizada muy hermosa,
realizada por Noah Snavely, estudiante de posgrado de la Universidad de Washington,
codirigida por Steve Seitz de la misma universidad
y Rick Szeliski en el Dpto. de Investigación de Microsoft. Una muy buena colaboración.
Y está en directo en la web, con tecnología de Seadragon.
Pueden apreciarlo cuando hacemos estos tipos de vistas,
en las que podemos bucear a través de las imágenes
y tener esta experiencia de resolución múltiple.
El orden espacial de estas imágenes es realmente significativo.
Los algoritmos visuales computarizados registraron estas imágenes en conjunto,
de modo que se corresponden con el espacio real en que se hicieron las tomas,
hechas en los Lagos Grassi, en las Montañas Rocallosas canadienses.
Aquí ven elementos
de diapositivas estabilizadas o imágenes panorámicas,
todas relacionadas espacialmente.
No sé si tengo tiempo para mostrarles otros entornos.
Algunos son mucho más espaciales.
Quisiera pasar directamente a uno de los conjuntos de datos originales de Noah;
este es uno de los primeros prototipos de Photosynth
por el que comenzamos en el verano,
y sirve para mostrarles lo que considero
la verdadera culminación de esta tecnología,
Photosynth. Y esto no necesariamente se aprecia
al ver los entornos que hemos subido a la red.
Tuvimos que ocuparmos de las capas y demás.
Esta es una reconstrucción de la Catedral de Notre Dame,
realizada totalmente con ordenador
a partir de imágenes tomadas de Flickr. Simplemente pongan Notre Dame en Flickr,
y podrán ver imágenes de personas en camiseta, del campus
y demás. Cada uno de estos conos anaranjados representa una imagen
perteneciente a este modelo.
Y estas son todas imágenes de Flickr,
relacionadas espacialmente de esta manera.
Podemos navegar simplemente de esta forma tan sencilla.
(Aplausos).
Saben, nunca pensé que terminaría trabajando en Microsoft.
Es muy gratificante tener una recepción así aquí.
(Risas).
Supongo que sabrán
que hay muchos tipos diferentes de cámaras:
desde las de teléfonos móviles hasta SLR profesionales,
gran parte de ellas ligadas
a este entorno.
Si puedo buscaré algunas de las más raras.
Muchas están bloqueadas por rostro, y demás.
Algunas de estas son realmente
una serie de fotografías... veamos.
Este es en realidad un póster de Notre Dame registrado correctamente.
Podemos acercanos desde el póster
hasta una vista física de este entorno.
Lo que importa realmente aquí es que podemos hacer algo
en el entorno social. Aquí se están tomando datos de todos,
de toda la memoria colectiva de
la apariencia visual de la Tierra,
y vinculándose en su totalidad.
Todas estas fotos se vinculan
y producen algo emergente
que es más que la suma de las partes.
Este es un modelo que surge de toda la Tierra.
Véanlo como la larga cola del trabajo de Tierra Virtual de Stephen Lawler.
Es algo cuya complejidad crece con el uso
y cuyos beneficios para los usuarios se amplían
a medida que lo utilizan.
Sus propias fotos se etiquetan con metadatos
que alguien introdujo.
Si alguien se toma el trabajo de etiquetar todos estos santos
e indicar quiénes son, mi foto de la Catedral de Notre Dame
se enriquece de pronto con todos esos datos,
y puedo utilizarla como punto de entrada para bucear en ese espacio,
en ese metaverso, usando las fotos de todos los demás,
y hacer un tipo de experiencia social de modelos
y usuarios cruzados de esa forma.
Por supuesto, una consecuencia de todo ello
consiste en modelos virtuales enormemente ricos
de cada parte interesante de la Tierra, tomados
no solo de vuelos de altura e imágenes satelitales
y demás, sino de la memoria colectiva.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: A ver si lo comprendo bien: ¿este software permitirá
en algún momento, en los próximos años,
que todas las imágenes compartidas por cualquier persona en cualquier parte del mundo
se vinculen?
BAA: Sí. Lo que hace realmente es descubrir
crear hipervínculos, si lo quieren, entre las imágenes.
Y lo hace
basándose en el contenido de las imágenes.
Y es realmente emocionante pensar en la riqueza
de la información semántica de muchas de estas imágenes.
Como en una búsqueda de imágenes en la web,
se introducen frases, y el texto de la página web
lleva gran cantidad de información acerca de la imagen.
Ahora, ¿qué sucede si dicha imagen se vincula con todas sus imágenes?
La cantidad de interconexión semántica
y de riqueza procedente de ello
es verdaderamente enorme. Es un efecto de red clásico.
CA: Blaise, es realmente increíble. Felicidades.
BAA: Muchas gracias.